hey guys welcome to a really special ask
IJ episode I'm excited to announce my
co-host say hello it's me say hello from
the other side clearly this is gonna be
going really well speaking of which my
first question is from JaJuan D who was
asking what was my favorite part of
having DJ mini Matt he's so just
energetic actually crazy because he is
extremely energetic he went for several
walks today I'm back home visiting my
family for the holidays and this little
guy is nuts I really I think my favorite
part is how fun he is I just love coming
home and we get to play and he's also a
DJ so clearly he's making some fantastic
music I'm so excited you're going to
hear his album it's coming along quite
nicely
yes Dena is asking if I'd ever consider
getting a cat they can be evil but
inspire some awesome video ideas I am
pretty much definitely allergic to cats
to be honest with you I'm also allergic
to dogs so I'm so so happy and so lucky
that I'm not allergic to this little guy
he's supposed to be a poodle Maltese we
think but I'm not really sure what he is
this year
you see his ear hello it's Maddie
he's been wondering if after all these
years
he's not even a year he's only five
months Matt you can't wonder about going
over everything especially not for years
because you're not a year old gotta move
you as close as you could see him oh
we're trying to look alike do you look
like panda purple Games is asking how do
I feel about becoming as successful as I
am it's interesting because anything
that I'm doing right now is something
that I have never planned on doing
everything that I'm doing now is all
things that just sort of happened and I
really just think that a lot of this is
because I'm so passionate about what I
am doing and I think if there's
something that you're passionate about
doing you have that ability to make that
become a career become something that
you can do for the rest of your life and
really enjoy it it is a lot of work and
I think that's something that a lot of
people don't realize that this whole
YouTube thing is it is a lot of work but
I really love what I'm doing and it
makes it all worth it when I go to
events and get to meet you guys and I'm
just excited that one day you guys will
be able to come to mini Matt's show
he'll be performing live he'll an
incredible DJ I promise he's moved on
Steven is asking what my favorite time
of the year is and actually my favorite
time is right now I absolutely love the
holiday season because I love being able
to come home and visit my family and I
also love buying gifts for people I
think it's one of my most favorite
things like I actually love giving gifts
more than receiving them and during the
holiday season everyone is extremely
giving and I absolutely love what PayPal
is doing this year to give back through
their PayPal giving fund they are doing
this thing called giving Tuesday which
is actually today so they are attempting
to break a world record for the most
money donated online in 24 hours and the
current record is 19 million dollars
raised in the UK for the tsunami in 2004
so if there's ever a time that you were
looking to give back today is the day to
do it because PayPal is adding one
percent on top of all donations of ten
dollars or more so check out PayPal comm
/ givingtuesday they have tons of
different charities if you don't already
have a favorite organization you can
definitely find one there what charity
are you gonna pick buddy huh
he's so tired I'm gonna cover him up
here you go you stay warm that's what
I'm coming back to Hawaii it's kind of
crazy because I remember taking this
photo with him I believe if I got the
story correct he might or might not have
seen that I tweeted that I was here
hiking or maybe you just randomly ran
into me I'm not sure but either way it's
kind of crazy to be able to run into
someone in the middle of a hike in the
middle of nowhere buddy answer your
question I'm not really sure what I'm
gonna go back to Hawaii and give it read
this correctly you can't bring in dogs
or animals from the mainland or
something crazy like that unless you
have a doctor's note or clearance or
something so I'm after looking into that
because I definitely wouldn't want to
leave a little Madi home alone and he
loves hikes so much so I would love to
be able to bring him so yeah I don't
know when I'm gonna be back but
hopefully soon grace X Colleen is asking
who I want to collab with on YouTube
there are so many amazingly talented
people that I would love to collab with
on YouTube I feel like the problem is I
travel a lot and all of my friends who
make videos on YouTube travel a lot so
to be able to get us all in the room at
the same time to make a video it's a
very difficult thing to do but hopefully
I will have some fun collabs free guys
soon mochi wants to know how I'm going
to spend the New Year's that's a really
good question
you know everyone does all these crazy
big celebrations for New Year's but I'm
not really really that into it but I
thought maybe you'd be really fun to do
something fun or crazy this year or
maybe I'll just sit and do absolutely
nothing which also is so much fun or
maybe I'll have a small party and play
rock band to be determined check out my
Twitter I'll figure it out and I'll
probably tweet about it um when do I
wanna do more vlogs with my drone that's
a good question because if you recall
the last video probably that I posted
with my drone I crashed it into a window
and I broke prop guards and a couple of
the propellers which those are simple
easy things to fix so I you just haven't
replaced them yet hopefully soon Jake
wants some dating advice okay
well be nice that helps I don't really
know I you know everyone will always ask
me like random things like as far as
like dating advice girls I don't really
have an answer for you because it's such
a broad subject that there's never one
thing that can be like hey you need to
do this to have a successful
relationship
I think patience and communication is
very important I'm not really sure what
kind of advice you're looking for so if
you could specify maybe in the next step
oh boy another advice question can have
any advice for a kid who's moving from
Pennsylvania to California be prepared
because everything is a lot more
expensive in California and not as
something that I had no idea about I
basically picked up and left home and
had nothing I had nothing except what
was in my suitcase I didn't I was
definitely struggling for the first
couple of years that I lived there I
think if you really want to make it work
you'll figure it out
and I mean III definitely figured it out
but by no means was easy so hopefully uh
hopefully you you have a place to live
even if you don't that's okay I didn't
either oh look who's here
ready who's here he says he's so sleepy
when asked two questions how are you I'm
doing well thank you how was everyone
everyone as well if DJ maybe Matt's name
wasn't Matt what would it be
I'm not sure what his name would be
honestly his name was sort of a joke the
whole story of Matt he's named after
nadeshot our friend who he probably
might or might not know here on YouTube
we went to the shelter after George Ezra
concert I didn't actually think that he
was still gonna be there because he was
such a cute little puppy and the rest of
his litter was already gone so me Matt
and my sister Jenna went to the shelter
and he was there he was sitting just in
the corner looking really not well and I
was like there he is and I picked him up
in my little hands and I was like this
is my baby I was like I'm gonna name him
at what do you think Matt and he was
just like oh the dog the dog was like so
that's name his name's Matt we did start
calling him Maddie because I actually
have a lot of friends named Matt so it
got a little confusing especially when
Jenna was like I'm gonna go get mad at
bath I was like I'm sorry what the dog
she's she's talking about the dog that's
the last of my questions I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode happy Holidays to
you and your family and don't forget to
check out paypal.com slash givingtuesday
because it's such an amazing cause and
hopefully you guys can contribute I love
you and I will see you in my next video
bye Maddie say bye this is his foot bye
does that look jetway they're actually
right on it right that's on paper and
pencil and tablets um give me turn it on
November is on pick on paper you don't
write on paper no you this is made for
paper paper paper